en la sierra peruana este pueblo lamenta
la muerte de kleimer rojas un joven de
23 años que salió de su casa para
protestar a favor del expresidente Pedro
castillo y nunca volvió su tía
acompañada de vecinos y amigos pide
justicia
justamente pedimos justicia la
desaparición de rojas es uno de al menos
20 casos de muerte registradas hasta el
momento en las protestas causadas por la
decisión del Congreso de destituir a
Pedro castillo y el ascenso al poder de
Dina boluarte como presidenta
el congreso en la sierra como se conoce
a la región andina de Perú las mayorías
apoyan a Castillo y su promesa de
combatir la desigualdad Crónica del país
a pesar de los escándalos de corrupción
que marcaron su gobierno de 17 meses
agricultores y campesinos han viajado
hasta Lima Para apoyar a Pedro Castillo
un profesor humilde como yo también es
el pueblo que representa Entonces eso es
la causa y el motivo que estoy acá eso
nosotros queremos la restitución de
nuestro presidente las manifestaciones
más violentas han tenido lugar en el sur
del país donde varios aeropuertos
permanecen cerrados en un intento
fallido por menguar las protestas la
presidenta Dina boluarte declaró el
estado de emergencia el miércoles pasado
por 30 días y pidió adelantar las
elecciones a diciembre del año 2023 de
momento el congreso se opone a eso
[Música]